try to encourage the children to be
quiet be happy to see him greet him with
a warm smile and be glad to see him now
this is the response don't forget to
give the kids this memo oh and flicking
on the Telly for a bit of shush isn't
encouraged what if the PAW Patrol theme
songs annoy him just ask the kids to be
quiet and still easy I mean I don't
agree with the modern woman take no but
but I am going to say like I think
that's OD like I don't think my husband
cares if the dishwasher's on if the
washer dries he's not that kind of guy I
just feel like he wouldn't care like
what type of man you know it's gonna be
like actually babe all the machines got
to be off that's a specific kind of guy
yeah I think this is in response to
1950s back then those machines were very
loud okay yeah so that's why he's
talking about obviously today
everything's silent yeah the message is
he wants to just come home to it silent
home nice is that what you were saying
yes outside is the case we want to come
home to peace I don't I don't think a
washing machine being lazy at home is is
chaos you see when when men hear chaos
it's just like arguing
yeah I don't think a man if a man's seen
his clothes getting washed in the
machine and it's making a bit of noise I
don't think a man's complaining I don't
think you've heard those 1950 machines
and I think three of them are going off
at once if three of them are going off
at once it sounds like a warzer and I'm
sure as well back in the 1950s a lot of
the jobs were manual noisy laborious so
coming home to a place where it's a bit
just clean it's a cool Serena I I
understand it but now it's it's not
really a problem half the machines I
probably don't even know it's on yeah
literally you can get like silent
machines because even washing machines
now yeah and I guess if she is a
housewife and she's been at home all day
she could do that stuff before so you
have free time together when you get
back as well some don't number six so
it's gonna tell us what not to do don't
greet him with problems or complaints
don't complain if he's late for dinner
count this as a minor compared with what
he might have gone through that day
now this is the response yes yes do not
annoy him with stories of how you
juggled two little ones with gastro
today while also having to work from
home because they couldn't go to daycare
oh and now you can also feel your tummy
starting to growl again he doesn't want
to hear it
I think this entire article is women
complaining about being married to men
that aren't that fast work for them to
stay home no no I think it's like not
every guy can afford for you to stay
home so like you're going to have to
work Point Blank period the end so this
whole this entire article I'm like baby
girl you better compete for the high
value man you better compete do
something I don't know it's like Deborah
lose the 50 pounds
you know this girl is not skinny you
know I don't even know what she looks
like okay seven make him feel
comfortable have him lean back in a
comfortable chair or suggest he lie down
in the bedroom have a cool or warm drink
ready for him and arrange his pillow and
offer to take off his shoes speak in a
low soft soothe and pleasant voice allow
him to relax and unwind
response sounds like a dream
moms this means no shouting mom rage
even if there's no one listening to you
and your man is looking at his phone
instead of the full-blown sibling fight
that is happening before his very eyes
no just keep him call calm allow him to
relax you don't need a drink he does
is very aggressive like she's just they
come across like no I am on violence
button activate you know some of the
girl that took off my man's shoes yeah
he must be mad
take off take off his own shoes
yeah would you would you guys like that
if a girl said sit down I'll take your
shoes off yes please differently so
feminine to do that as well remember
you're coming to America are you gonna
do that
no I I tried it so he's just not into
that like he's right he wants to I've
offered he wants to take off his own
boots but to be honest so they're
military boots so they don't really
smell the best song I'm glad he was like
no thank you no thank you
um eight
listen to him
you may have a lot of things to tell him
but the moment of his arrival is not
that time let him talk first
oh shut up all right again he doesn't
care about your day or that your boss is
a jerk or that his baby needs a change
right now you've got risotto on the
stove that needs stirring or that his
pride and joy firstborn dropping the
F-bomb at preschool today just zip it
Zip Zip Scrolls a lot of preschool he's
already dropping that I think this is
peach mom from Twitter I don't know if
you guys remember that this lady went
viral for making cartoons about how much
he resents her husband but she doesn't
think that they're offensive cartoons at
all at all
now last one make the evening his
never complain if he does not take you
out to dinner or other places of
entertainment Instead try to understand
his world of strain and pressure he
needs to come home and relax
response yep we've got it he's had a
hard day his Barista Coffee that he got
to drink without having to microwave 10
times over and didn't have the Two
Sugars he asked for and when he got into
the office kitchen that was out of sugar
he didn't have the time to he didn't
take time he didn't have time to return
to the cafe because someone in the
office had a birthday that he had to
stay out and eat cake
so very specific this one okay so so now
she is apparently married to a high
value man and still complaining I guess
whatever author was inspired by this but
you know what it is this is interesting
it's because like women don't want men
who make the same amount of money or
less than them right so he goes and he
earns more and that probably means that
he has like a higher demanding job than
you and so it would make sense that he
might incurb more stress and then want
more peace at home but then they're
they're still complaining but they won't
date like the broke guy so I'm just I
don't think women really know what they
want I don't know I think women will
always find something to complain about
yeah yeah
they will actually go out of their way
to find something to complain about
because if everything's going well then
they start to like what's going on why
is everything going well something's
wrong right now so what do you guys
think of the dating advice from the
1950s how'd it sound some of it had some
really key valuable points which I think
some Modern women if they took half of
this they'd be able to get a man should
we implement this in wife's school oh
yeah if you did that people were getting
married it'll be like how long can we
keep quiet
do it that'd be a good episode that'd be
hard for a meeting we need to start
selling toys when to play with like
fidgeting toys so they can just keep
quiet
learn to read again the last thing yes
how long can you go without social media
imagine two minutes the last statement
was the same the guy never takes his
wife out
no she doesn't complain when he doesn't
don't complain if he doesn't all I ever
think you out never complain if he does
not take you out to dinner or other
places of entertainment you don't need
to complain you can just ask hey honey I
feel like I haven't gone on a date in a
while diving that's something we could
do this weekend you don't need to
complain yeah it's about I think the
best about the delivery as well so it's
not the stuff you're saying no if you
come across in like a feminine way and
and you cooperate and correctly and it's
it's not a thing a spectral way the guy
who actually want to I can't even
imagine like you haven't taken me out on
a date in a while and honestly I just I
don't appreciate it I feel like I'm
being neglected this just sucks like I'd
responded I'm not going to
it's all about just compromising
communication to some degree right yes
tonality is very very important like men
really take on the tonality of how you
speak to us like we mentioned earlier
about respect and all these things a lot
of it because a man couldn't talk to me
a certain way with that bass in his
voice you think it's not gonna happen
because with men there's always that
undefended underlying threat of violence
it's not that little women women
sometimes think they can act Wild and
we're just going to take it it's like no
disrespected suspect
are you entitled to being taken on a
date by a husband
no I don't think I'm entitled I think he
wants
he's the one trying to go out I'm always
trying to stay home I'm like we have
food at home he's like oh come on let's
go have fun as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible